there are those who say they hate
Christmas there are those who say they
hate Christmas no there's actually
really really really do
it may have struck you ladies and
gentlemen that there's a big
relationship between this marvelous time
of year and living in a one-party state
nothing makes me think more than at this
time
yeah of our oldest humanity's oldest
enemy the authoritarian dictatorship
where you can't go anywhere without
listening to the same music where you
can't go anywhere without hearing the
name of the great leader and his son the
dear leader we're all broadcasts all
songs all jokes all references are just
for that magic few weeks just exactly
like living in [ __ ] North Korea now
there's an older there's a much older
objection to this and when I remember
when I look back as we all do don't we
at this time here short childhood to
those dear dead days of long ago what I
remember is the beautiful Carol that was
coined for us by Tom Lehrer and with
your permission I want to share it with
you so that we can get the ex back in
Xmas and some of you may by now have the
song sheet but I thought I would do my
own rendition first a cappella and then
as a community as a community as
Americans my fellow Americans we'd all
do it together
all right are we agreed very well so is
the opening of our chests I go like this
and this is how I remember it I get my
eyes closed
the main Russ's christmas time is here
by golly disapproval would be falling
deck the halls with hunks of holly fill
the cup and don't say when kill the
turkeys ducks and chickens makes the
punch drag out the dickens even though
their prospect sickens brother here we
again relation sparing no expense Oh
send some useless old utensil or a
matching pen and pencil just the thing I
need how nice don't stand underneath
grand bay fly by